welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
I am remained The only voice of Common
Sense here because Eurovision returned
to the UK this week after 25-year
absence supposed to be of course in
Ukraine who won it last time but uh
obviously Ukraine can't host it so
Liverpool has the dubious honor of being
host City uh and that's fine and
everyone I know seems to be wildly
excited about this apart from me because
I think Eurovision is a stain on
Humanity ah now the first of two
semi-finals was affected on audiences
last night head of the Grand Final on
Saturday fancy Eurovision is a
world-class Festival of the Arts an
exhibition of the best of pop music and
offer Recollections may vary take a look
at this
[Music]
evening
[Applause]
[Music]
Dominic
that last step we're called we are the
winners from Lithuania the one thing
lithuania's never won is enemy
um unbelievable I'm gonna bring in now
Sharon Osborne and Louis wolf Sharon's
with me Louie's wherever Louis is uh the
parents we're gonna try and put these
and I of course he is they're going to
try and persuade me that this ludicrous
fast is actually a credible tournament
Louis you go first try come on
listen I watched the semi-final last
night I know you do but I think it's
brilliant fun I watch it every single
year there are some really good songs
you played all the bad ones but there's
some Abba came from us Celine Dion
Johnny Logan so many great people it's
light entertainment at its best Pairs
and you may not like it but I love it I
think it's honestly sure I bet Sharon
well the thing is it doesn't surprise me
you like it because when we did
America's Got Talent together you always
put the Nutty acts like that through and
it was down to me on behalf of the
Grateful American people to buzz them
off you love this crap
I do it's not crap it is because there's
no cultural it is it's very interesting
to see all these different cultures and
what they consider to be entertainment
and it's very interesting look a little
bit you know the worst thing about it
and I'm gonna say this is somebody who
went to Ukraine to interview president
zielinski and his wife and I've
obviously done a lot of stuff about the
Ukraine war I really didn't like Ukraine
winning it last year simply because the
country's at War and I don't and I'm
sure they're going to probably win it
again this year for the same reason the
moment any competition to me goes into
what I call just transparent virtue
signaling they weren't the best act we
all know that they'll Behavior then it's
not a competition
it's something else it's like it's
people just ticking boxes no it's people
that like other people peers and try and
understand that you know the worst thing
Louie I I when I went to Ukraine I came
through the train station to go back to
Poland and the train station manager
gave me the hat that the winner of the
Ukraine that that hat he gave it to the
train station guy in Kiev and signed it
and he and the guy gave it to me uh and
honestly I was the last thing I wanted
to take I had to pretend to be happy you
should have put it on for a picture
I love Ukraine I love ukrainians I want
them to win this War I don't want to see
them keep winning competitions simply
because they're at War it's ridiculous
they only won last year I mean I've
voted for them maybe 10 times last year
I wanted them to win because of course
pretty good
yes okay let's pairs it was a good song
we listened to the songs Sharon and I
are in the music business it wasn't a
good song it wasn't a good song it was
it was a good song
I'm too sad but when was that 1970 right
Celine Dion Johnny Logan box Fizz loads
of people I watched last night there's
some amazing things
I thought I thought that Switzerland was
good did you like Switzerland Louis
I did but I love Finland I know he's a
bit crazy but I loved it I also loved
Israel I thought it was awesome
my other problem with it is it's a
complete Carver where all the countries
basically look after their mates none of
it none of the Voting is genuine they'll
often take the best song and obliterates
it because it's not from a country
that's part of that impact peers you are
wrong the best song Always Wins always
yeah but the bar is unbelievable a the
bar is unbelievably low for that title
and be the best song never wins but it's
about entertainment peers it's about
personality
presentation all of that well let's say
this this is the UK entry this year have
a listen to some of this
yeah please
[Applause]
[Music]
stop that look this is my point this is
my point about that that is that you
hear that in every Euro trash disco at
three in the morning when they want
people to leave they turn on that kind
of stuff when they want to kick people
out it's not it represents you today
there's not a person under 50 who would
listen to that and not think it's
horrified you're wrong
peers in Lithuania at three in the
morning that's what that's for no and
the idea that YouTube you do actually
know your music this is what offends me
you do married to one of the greatest
entertainment weaned on rock music your
father one of the great Rock managers
and you Louis Awards produce some of the
great pop bands of all time the fact
that you have straight faces because
it's as you try and persuade me that
this garbage is serious music I love it
I do
are you both gonna watch the whole thing
absolutely you're going to watch it
absolutely Lily what about I'm not
getting through
no it wasn't great it wasn't great it
wasn't great oh really Eurovision that
wasn't great
yeah
because there are some great songs
neither of you believe yourself
no no it's not it's about it makes
people happy this is why I had to be the
lead judge on America's Got Talent
because Sharon would go nuts and put
these sort of Acts through and I would
have to then save
pears does a massive Market
150 million people can't be wrong they
can and they are it the whole thing is a
complete terracy it's a travesty it's
not Sensational BBC I've done a great
job
it's amazing amazing um
it's not just the songs we watch for the
clothes the dancing all the outrageous
the girls
differences all right yes just play me a
little bit we played at the start please
this is this is closed it's the music
it's the whole the whole ensonance just
remind ourselves of that it's everything
there we go
foreign
[Music]
it is utter nonsense I will not be
anywhere near a TV on Saturday night yes
Louis lovely to see you though and
Sharon lovely to see you always a
pleasure looking well shot I know that
off camera you'll both said to me you
know what you're right but that's what
normally happens that's a problem
I keep it real